We will now talk about the breakpoint graph,
the workhorse of genome
rearrangement studies.
Let's take a look at two genomes, a red
genome P, and a blue genome Q.
And now let's arrange the black edges of Q
in the same order they
are arranged in genome P.
So they will be arranged as
+a -b -c +d.
And how the genome Q will
look like in the case of this new
arrangement of its black edges?
We do not change genome Q.
We just show it differently.
So after we look at genome Q:
so, after a we should go to c.
That's what we do.
After c, we should go to b.
After b, we should go to -d, and
after -d, we should go to a.
So that's a new representation of Q, where
black edges are
arranged exactly in the same way as they
are arranged in P.
As soon as we've done it, we can
superimpose genome P with genome Q because
black edges are arranged identically, and
we will
get something that is called the
breakpoint graph.
It's absolutely unclear yet what is the
value breakpoint graph,
so let's learn a few things about the
breakpoint graph.
So the first question, red and black edges
in the breakpoint graph...
what do they correspond to?
Of course, they correspond to genome P,
because breakpoint
graph is simply obtained by superimposing
of P and Q.
What about blue and black edges?
What do they correspond to?
Of course, they correspond to genome Q.
And now we ask a strange question, what
about red and blue edges?
What do they correspond to?
And here, what happens when we limit our
attention to
red and blue edges, and they do not
corresponding to anything.
So a thing that you may notice, however,
is that
red and blue edges form alternating red-blue
cycles in the breakpoint graph.
Why?
Because you may notice that at every node,
there is
a single red edge and a single blue edge
meeting.
And therefore the resulting graph must
consist of
alternating red-blue cycle,
after every red edge,
there is a blue edge, and after every blue
edge, there is a red edge.
We'll pay attention to one important
parameter of
the breakpoint graph, which is the cycle
number.
The cycle number is simply the number of
red-blue alternating cycles in the
breakpoint graph.
Why do we care about the cycle number?
But before I explain this,
let's try an example,
let's construct
the breakpoint graph for these two
genomes, P and Q.
P consists of a single chromosome and Q
consists of 2 chromosomes.
The first thing we do, we arrange black
edges of
Q in the same order they are present in
genome P.
So it will be this arrangement of black
edges in Q.
And then we will have to represent genome
Q in this order.
How do we do this?
Well, we start from a.
After a, we know that
we should go to -c.
Afterwards we go to -f.
Afterwards, we go to -e, and finally
we return back to +a.
And we continue the same way to show the
smaller chromosomal with just
two synteny blocks, right here.
As soon as we represent it, genome Q, in
this way, we can superimpose P and Q, and
we get the breakpoint graph.
And after we remove black edges from the
breakpoint graph, we see that the cycle
number of P and Q is equal to 3, because
there are three cycles in this graph.
Now,
given genome P, I want to ask you, what
is the genome Q that maximizes the cycle
number?
Well, the cycle number will be maximized
if every cycle will be small.
And the shortest cycle consist of just two
edges, one red edge and one blue edge.
Which means this is the breakpoint graph,
with the maximum number of
alternating cycles.
And of course, this breakpoint graph
corresponds to the
case when genome Q and genome P are
identical.
And the number of cycles in this graph is
of course simply the number of blocks in
genome P.
So in this case, the number is 4.
So it's important to realize that genome
rearrangements affect
red-blue cycle.
Every two breaks makes its mark on the
breakpoint graph.
And we know that starting from the
breakpoint graph between genome
P and Q, doesn't matter what series of
rearrangement nature takes.
That will be the breakpoint graph of two
identical genomes, and we know how it
looks like.
It looks like the identity breakpoint
graph with the maximum
number of cycles.
And we will explore this fact, despite
the fact that the series of 2-break
transforming P into Q is unknown,
we know the number of cycles between P and
Q, in this case 2,
must change into the maximum number of
cycles between P and Q,
which in this case is 4.
And this is just an example of one
possible scenario for rearrangement of
genome P into genome Q, but doesn't matter
what this scenario is.
It always will be the change from
cycle(P,Q) to the maximum number of
cycles in the graph.
And armed with this observation,
we are ready to prove the 2-break theorem
that will
prove to be very important for our analysis of
the random breakage model.